[Música]
olá bom dia a todos
hoje vou falar um pouco sobre tecnologia
social
primeiramente você conhece esses números
no brasil mais de 15 milhões de pessoas
vivem abaixo da linha extremas de
pobreza
o dim o desemprego no brasil atinge mais
de 12 milhões de pessoas no fim de 2008
a polícia em falta de saneamento básico
matam 1.7 milhão de crianças por ano
o que você tem a ver com tudo isso
combater a desigualdade erradicar a fome
e combater a pobreza melhorar a saúde e
promover a inclusão social como podemos
ajudar a isso aconteceu
uma das formas das formas é por meio da
tecnologia social
mas o que a tecnologia social tecnologia
social um produto processo método que
tem como objetivo ser de baixo custo
simples de fácil aplicabilidade
reaplicabilidade e causa um grande
impacto para resolver um problema social
para quem não sabe existe uma grande
diferença entre tecnologia social e
tecnologia como ensinou a tecnologia
convencional sempre irá buscar o lucro
ea movida por interesses corporativos ou
seja empresas
já a tecnologia social os que o
desenvolvimento da sociedade e promover
a inclusão social
nós nunca sabemos ao certo quando a
tecnologia social foi inventada mas uma
das pessoas que ajudou ela expandiu foi
grande
grande fã dos maiores pacifistas do
mundo que a lutar pela independência da
índia a inglaterra ensinou a população a
usar a rota de fé
assim a indy ficou livre economicamente
nem o terra e uma frase muito legal dele
é da produção em massa para a produção
das massas ou seja das pessoas que
trabalhavam na empresa para elas mesmo
trabalharem por si mesmos
mas como esse tipo de tecnologia
consegue nos trazer tantos benefícios é
fato ela realmente nos três benefícios
por exemplo a cisterna que ajudou no
semiárido do brasil de primeira
necessidade de água nos tempos de seca
ou seja ela captava água nos tempos de
chuva e não sempre de ser que eles
usavam aquela água
outro tipo de tecnologia social foi a
fossa séptica que ajudou nas zonas
rurais do brasil acabando com os esgotos
a céu aberto
e você como pode ajudar a tecnologia
social expandir
converse com seus amigos colegas sobre a
importância deste tipo de tecnologia e
promova reuniões com a sua comunidade
para debater os seus problemas e como
como podem resolvê los
se você quiser aprender mais existem
dois filmes que você poderá assistir um
é o filme o menino que descobre o vento
que fala sobre uma tecnologia social e
outro filme de gandhi que retrata a vida
dele
muito obrigado pela sua atenção
[Aplausos]
[Música]